Interest rates are how much money costs.
Ali's money doesn't cost very much.
People are going to use more of it.
It's pretty straight forward.
So,
um,
it takes the breaks off things because it's less expensive to risk.
I mean,
that's why government to manipulate the interest rates,
right?
When,
when they want to stimulate the economy,
they drive down the interest rates to make money cheaper so that people spend
more of it.
So it certainly contributed to the housing boom,
although I don't think it contributed nearly as much as crookedness did.
It was a combination of radical innovation,
which is always dangerous,
although also necessary and regulatory failure.